hello everyone and welcome to a very
interesting game from 1978 it was played
in seattle and it's a game between
michael darby and yasir sarawan uh you
all know yasir he's a well a very well
known personality in the chess world
that this game comes as a suggestion
from uh sanji chamblook and it's uh
it's a really fun game you guys will
enjoy it a lot and i thought maybe uh
since we're in between two big
tournaments so we could show a nice fun
game as tomorrow is the start of the
year things masters we're going to be
covering that uh so i thought this would
be a nice nice way to
unwind a little bit and yes as you've
seen in the thumbnail it does feature
the move that was in the thumbnail so uh
let's see now let's see uh what it is
and it's um uh it's a very interesting
um situation in the chess world bobby
fischer uh disappeared no one knows
where he is uh and natalie karpov became
world champion without playing a
match for the world church championship
match you know it's a it's a fun time to
be in
inches so here uh we have no uh photo of
michael darby so i'm using a hoodie to
honor the hoodie guy hope you guys are
doing the same uh let's check it out so
darby with the white pieces opens with
d4 we have d6 by us
e4 transposing into the pits defense and
now g6 going uh for a sort of a modern
approach here uh we have c4 and e5 now
striking in the center and saying that i
am very happy if you want to trade
queens this is perfectly fine for black
so bishop to e3 of course a white uh uh
not interested in this bishop to g7 by
yasser and now knight to c3 we have
knight to c6 and knight g to e2 and here
black plays knight to h6 yasser doesn't
want to go knight to f6 because uh this
is uh well this is a was a well-known
line in those days and he uh well as it
would seem uh i guess he played it quite
a lot he even mentions it in his book uh
saying that you kind of have to play d5
here but it's also perfectly fine for
example the 597 and then both of the
knights will be helping out with the
control of the f5 square you're gonna
castle push f5 and
strike very strongly against white
center but here we have f3 just uh
solidifying in the center and now easter
waits no longer he executes f5 right
away
and now queen d2 uh going after the
knight on h6 the thing is if you go d5
sorry uh if you go d5 now uh then we get
knight to e7 queen to d2 attacking the
knight and after knight to f7 both
players can castle for example castles
castles king to b1 a nice prophylactic
move uh and the game continues so this
is what uh
white should play and again it's
something that yasser mentions that the
d5 definitely is the move here but after
queen to d2 the game becomes a lot more
interesting so we're threatening to win
a piece here but it also gives yasir a
chance to start um some very interesting
tactics here and he starts with f
captures on e4 he says uh you are
welcome to capture my knight and h6 but
it's not really a free piece i'm just
gonna play queen h4 check and win back
the piece so if we we go for this just
queen h4 check we're going to play g3
queen captures here and the black is
just up material uh even if we play
something like knight captures on e4 uh
we're gonna play queen captures on d2
with check king captures e captures on
d4 and we're up upon it's a beautiful
pass to d pawn and we still have the
bishop pair so black's position is much
much better here this would be winning
for black
uh so okay after f captures on e4 we
have d5 now challenging the knight
finally white pushes this pawn to d5 and
now uh what do you play well uh knight
to d4 is what you should play but it's
not what he asked or played the azer
played e captures an f3 and now the game
really becomes interesting best for
white is to just capture the knight for
example captures on c6 and now uh what
do you play here as black you can't
really well you could play f captures on
e2 but it's not going to be all that
great because now we're going to play
bishop to g5 and how are you saving the
uh the black queen the pawn and bishop
are covering all the squares there's not
much you can do if you play captures on
f1 bring a queen into the game with
check rook captures and again you have
this uh problem uh that's uh well
you will not be able to solve this so
instead after d captures in c6 you will
have to play f2 with check and then it's
a completely crazy game but white should
always be better bishop captures knight
to g4 now the game continues with black
sort of having the attack but not really
so this is what happens after e captures
an f3 that's why knight to d4 was a bit
more sound but okay knight to g3 by
yasser and now sorry by darby and not
knight to d for by us or
asking uh white are you going to capture
on h6 because then i have knight to c to
check but this position is incredibly
difficult for black to play and i'm sure
yasser knew this uh even after playing
knight to d4 because this will just be
better for white for example captures
captures and captures knight to c to
check after king to d2 it's not all that
uh
all that great we're going to capture
the rook but now not even
developing the bishop to go quickly
after the knight we're just gonna play g
captures on f3 and now uh we're going to
develop the bishop and capture the
knight there's no way for black to save
this knight uh for example if rook to f8
we're going to play bishop to e2 even
defend our pawn here and next move we're
going to capture let's say queen f6 rook
captures on a1 and now white is just
much much better here so instead after
knight d4 instead of going for this
bishop the g5 was played and it looks
very very tricky but it allows yasser to
play the move that after so many years
uh uh got the game uh to be uploaded on
this channel and that move is queen
captures on g5 that's the move from the
thumbnail so the queen the bishop is
attacking the queen and we just capture
that bishop so we can look at this one
more time in slow motion you can see
that there's really nothing defending
the black queen so it's a straight out
queen sacrifice or rather a queen trait
for a bishop but that's kind of the
definition of a queen sacrifice and
darby was uh probably a bit confused
here but okay queen captures on g5 and
now knight to g4 and the position is not
uh all that clear
uh because black has so much stuff here
in front of the white king this night
covering these squares these this night
covering these these squares uh the pawn
covering these squares so uh that's uh
that's a lot happening here the bishop
can come to h6 it will attack the queen
so what can you do here uh obviously if
you play g captures on f3 we just
capture the pawn with check and pick up
the white queen so that's out of the
question so after knight g4 we have
knight g to e4 by white
uh sort of uh well just improving the
position uh but now uh we have knight to
c2 with check and here indeed you could
go bishop to h6 but if yasser played
this then white probably thought okay
i'm just going to give back the queen
and that's it with a move like knight to
f6 check uh hence the knight e4 idea and
after let's taking a fade just queen g4
uh we're going to play knight the c2
with check king f2 now bishop captures
on g for knight captures on g4 and after
a nice capture fest here knight captures
on a1 g captures on f3 uh it would uh
all come down to this position where
black would have to decide what to do
here but there is a move for black and
that is bishop to c1 so it's all very
very hard to spot uh but this is how you
save both the knight and the bishop uh
but not uh not forever because after
let's say bishop d3 bishop capture
sirius you defend the knight but now
knight to e2 we're going to prevent the
bishop from capturing next move we're
going to play rogue b1 attack the bishop
the bishop is out of useful squares and
then we're gonna win the knight and uh
well it's a sort of an equalish game uh
but okay after knight g captain knight
g4 we have knights the c to uh check
bayassa right away
and now uh black white has to play king
to d2 with king to d2 white is still
just better but white played king to d1
it seems like it's the same idea uh
maybe he just didn't want to put the
the king on a dark square because after
king to d2 uh what happens if just
bishop to h6 well it again it's not a
problem we're just gonna capture
and after night captures king captures
in c2 so uh although it's uh a bit uh
odd playing the uh the king here on a
dark square visually as this could be
you know a problem it's actually the
best move but okay king d1 was played
but now yasser doesn't go after the rook
he plays knight c to e3 with check and
again
white is not dead here uh he he still
has to play king to d2 but here probably
why i thought okay yasser sacrificed the
queen for nothing he just wants to
get a perpetual here he played king to
e1 and now probably he was expecting uh
knight to see to checking the 193 check
and a nice perpetual here but after king
to e1 here comes bishop to h6 by yasser
uh capturing on g2 first before bishop
h6 is better because it prevents white
from just giving back the queen uh but
they are
decided that this is perfectly fine as
well
and now you have to play g captures on
f3 and just give up the queen but white
wanted to keep everything he played
queen to h4 and now yasser just destroys
uh everything f captures on g2 now
threatening to pick up the rook with
czech or even the bishop here pretty
much depends on what white plays so rook
the g1 now comes g captures on f1
bringing a queen into the game
rook captures an f1 and here just knight
the g2 check and he was in this position
on move 18 yes this is uh only move 18
even though we've shown a lot of
sidelines uh but that uh michael darby
resigned in the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so really a
wonderful game uh that you know uh it's
a pre-engine era so anything uh you know
you could play pretty much anything and
still uh
create a a brilliant game like this
because uh well if you if your opponent
didn't know that what you're doing is uh
you know
bad by default then you could you could
get away with it so here after night the
gt check of course he resigned because
whatever he plays we're just gonna pick
up the queen on h4 and now we've won
back our queen and we're just up too
much material so of course it makes no
sense for
for white to
continue playing this so yeah only 18
moves knight to g2 check white resigns
and another uh brilliant victory by
oscar we haven't shown many games by
asura on this channel but those that we
have are simply brilliant if you
remember the one against
anatoly karpov where uh karpov's second
forgot to
inform karpov of a certain sacrifice and
then yasser used it and totally crushed
karpov
if you haven't seen it do check that out
as well i might even put it in the
description below uh so do check if it's
in the description
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it a nice light one uh for
our preparation for the big tournament
tomorrow the earthings masters is
starting i would like to thank the emoji
pillow on my couch odell lucifer 45
non-commercial ep dale cook and onward
the 95 american flag numa for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing or rather uh
starting the coverage of the air things
masters checking up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day